further an exposition of this kind
constitutes the first part of science
because the existence of spirit qua
primary is nothing but the immediate or
the beginning but not yet it's returning
to itself the element of immediate
existence is therefore what
distinguishes this part of science from
the others the statement of this
distinction leads us into a discussion
of some fixed ideas which usually crop
up in this connection
section 35 is another very short
paragraph and we might be tempted to
pass over it but Hegel is making is
always important points during it and
I've got them sort of sketched out here
on our chalkboard I do want to sort of
pick up actually where it ends he says
that the statement of this distinction
leads us into a discussion of some fixed
ideas which usually crop up in this
connection what is it what does he mean
there remember he's just talked about
the problem that in modernity we tend to
work with these fixed ideas that we take
for granted of you know pick whatever
could be theological ideas like God
could be notions of what science
actually is you know if in fact you're
always when we talk about science in
terms of Hegel you're always thinking in
terms of science as conceived of by the
popularizers of science and the
scientific method as pot in your you
know high school biology class or
something like that that would be an
example of something that Hegel would
call a fixed idea something that is
unquestioned that one says I know this
at least and now I can build out from
this with dialectical philosophy
everything gets called into question
everything gets gets put into the
microscope and scrutinized everything
gets gets brought in for analysis and
some of the fixed ideas turned out to be
inadequate precisely because they're
fixed so he's in the next sections he's
going to be carrying out you know some
some diagnosis and discussion of those
so let's see what's actually going on in
this section he says that spirit you
know what we're looking at right now
this developmental process the
exposition of this kind constitutes the
first part of what of science why well
because we have to begin with something
and rather
just beginning by opening up a textbook
and saying aha
there are science instead what we have
to do is pay attention to things we have
to actually see what's there we have to
observe we have to follow things out we
have to resist the temptation to say AHA
now I know it all and actually keep
paying attention that's why it's called
the phenomenology we're paying attention
to what it is
that presents itself to us as we're
carrying out this intellectual inquiry
which is tracing back to the very
beginnings of consciousness the very
grounds of consciousness and then seeing
where it is gone not just in the
abstract but through human history
through through this vast process of
stops and starts and half you know
successes and three steps forward two
steps back and other three steps forward
and sometimes going off to the side as
well so he says that the existence of
spirit as primary is nothing but the
immediate or the beginning or immediate
existence and when we see this term
immediate we want to keep in mind that
what's going on there is is two things
Hegel is pointing out every time you use
that word immediate it's really a trick
word because nothing is immediate things
only present themselves as being
immediate as being what's you know there
and can be just assured and we don't
have to think about it anymore we now
move on to cooler stuff within this word
is a sort of you might say contradiction
or privation or a crossing or taking
away of media see that is a mediation
and the immediate presents itself as
immediate precisely because
we take it as such and don't look at how
it's connected to other things and how
it has what it is and what it will
become and what it can do through those
other things that's to notice mediation
or immediacy that's to get away from the
immediate so he says that what's going
on is at the beginning when we're doing
phenomenology we have to begin with the
immediate we have to begin at you know
the elements the beginning places and
we're not going to stay there though
because what makes this spirit or mind
or Geist in German is that it involves a
process of return to itself and and
probably I shouldn't just appoint you
know one thing here is after it manages
to return to itself now it's going to
incorporate this again and spiral around
and return to itself another time and
you know I won't burden the chalkboard
with all sorts of scribbles and spirals
and circles but you get the idea there's
going to be this ongoing process and
that's what he's describing in the next
several paragraphs in a little bit more
detail but but talking about the formal
structure of them
the immediate existence of spirit
consciousness contains the two moments
of knowing and the objectivity negative
to knowing since it is in this element
of consciousness that spirit develops
itself and explicate sits moments these
moments contain that antithesis and they
all appear as shapes of consciousness
the science of this pathway is the
science of the experience which
consciousness goes through the substance
and its movement are viewed as the
object of consciousness consciousness
nose and comprehends only what falls
within its experience for what is
contained in this is nothing but
spiritual substance and this - as object
of the self but spirit becomes object
because it is just this movement of
becoming an other to itself that is
becoming an object to itself and of
suspending this other nests and
experience is the name we give just to
this movement in which the immediate the
unexperienced the abstract whether it be
of sensuous but still in sense being or
only thought of as simple becomes
alienated from itself and then returns
to itself from this alienation and is
the only then revealed for the first
time in its actuality and truth just as
it then has become a property of
consciousness also
we need to begin with the immediate
existence of spirit the immediate
existence of mind the immediate
existence of a distinctively human way
of relating ourselves to things out
there and ourselves and other people and
the objects and ideas that we use to
make sense of things and Eagle says that
consciousness contains two moments that
are going to be placed into antithesis
with each other and this is going to
happen in terms of other similar moments
as well like for example truth and
certainty you know they're going to
split apart and this is this is integral
to the dialectical process as Hegel
understands there's always the small
turn they're splitting this doubling
that takes place but that in the you
know there's an antithesis the things
stand against each other and they look
like they're just complete
contradictions to each other notice that
what we don't have here is thesis
antithesis synthesis right instead we
have two things as both being what
consciousness is and an antithesis
arising between them which then has to
be overcome but it's going to be
overcome over and over and over again in
different ways so we have knowing
knowledge and in knowing the subject is
related to something else which it knows
it takes it in it makes it its own for
me to know what Hegel is talking about
is for me to make that my own to bring
it within the sphere of my own
consciousness and to be in a certain way
assured of it and that's when we start
sliding over into objectivity the
objectivity negative to knowing when we
think that we know something can we
actually be sure that we know
do we have knowledge of our knowledge to
have knowledge squared and what is it
that we know there is the act of knowing
and then there is the object of knowing
so we have all these antitheses going on
now if we wanted to just sort of you
know separate everything out then we
would stop there and that's where you
know we would end but that's not what
happened throughout human history the
history of thought the history of
consciousness
instead Hegel says each time that we
have something like this these moments
our incorporated spirit develops itself
explicates these moments figures out for
itself at that time what is knowing for
me now what does it mean to know what is
objectivity or what is the mode of the
things that I'm actually trying to get
out there and get to know or get inside
myself and get to know it's going to
come up with different answers at
different points and it's going to bring
these two that seem to be totally
irreconcilable back together into some
sort of not necessarily harmony but some
sort of synthesis and he says they all
appear as shapes of consciousness and
there's more than one shape of
consciousness more than one Gestalt more
than one form and so we can trace out a
pathway which is the dialectical process
of development that he's been talking
about in the earlier paragraphs and we
can arrange them into a kind of order
not just a sequential order but an order
which you could think of it as an order
that's getting bigger and bigger and
wider and more complex as time goes up
because some of these early shapes may
show up as having been assimilated and
reoccurring down here in a different
form in any case is more than three of
course but
you know using a chalkboard this is what
he calls the pathway and that's what the
phenomenology of spirit as opposed to
just say the phenomenology of you know
paying attention to my own experience
right here right now the phenomenology
of spirit trying to figure out what is
it to be a human being by looking at the
history of development and a thought is
charting out these shapes of
consciousness many of which were long
past but in order to fully understand
how we got to where we are we need to
sort of go back through them so we can
we can fully grasp them we need to sort
of relive that and this brings us to
over here what is this this is what
science is for Hegel science again is
vishton shock does this unifying
synthesizing integrating ever expanding
human knowledge which is also reflective
and able to take take stock of itself
and it's going to be a science of the
experience of consciousness of spirit of
human beings who have made contributions
that advanced the dialectic over the
course of time some of them are going to
be very generic Hegel's not going to
name a lot of names of the phenomenology
'he's not gonna say and I have in mind
here Voltaire er you know we have to
sort of read between the lines with many
of these but if you know enough about
those thinkers you'll be able to
recognize as we go through these shapes
what's actually happening with them so
that's the first part of this paragraph
now we actually need to do a little bit
of a race sure just so we can clear the
board because he's gonna see a few other
things that are particularly important
he says a consciousness knows and
comprehend is only what falls within its
experience for what is contained in this
is nothing but spiritual substance this
too is an object of the self but spirit
spirit becomes object because spirit is
this movement of objectifying itself of
becoming other to itself finish put the
other over here actually because he
hasn't as it manages to make itself into
an object it becomes other to itself is
this something that we have experience
with sure I mean when you look in the
mirror and you have the uncanny thing
that you know you're looking at yourself
you're like just do I really look like
that is that wasn't really how I appear
even better film yourself see how you
actually come across or record yourself
you become an object to yourself and
thereby also become another to yourself
I have this experience what I sometimes
when I read through my old writings from
years ago which are you know many of
them are quite good some of them are
actually quite bad but I'll read them
and all I'll say man I guess I must have
written this I'm really kind of
surprised that I did
that's a grasp of yourself as somebody
other when you it doesn't necessarily
have to be in terms of scholarship to
when you rise to an occasion when you
turn out to be more of a jerk or a
bastard than you originally thought that
you were you surprise yourself you are
becoming an object you are becoming
another to yourself other people can
turn you into an object as well it's
possible for you to objectify your son
so spirit becomes an object to itself
and it also has to suspend this other
Ness and bring it back to itself that's
what the process of spirits as active
really is suspending this other Ness he
says experiences the name we give to
just this movement in which the
immediate the unexperienced we start out
with that and it becomes alienated from
itself that is it becomes other alien
means other from itself
and then it's reincorporated back into
this so this is happening subjectively
on the part of consciousness the
conscious being becomes other to itself
and reincorporate sit it's also
happening with what it is that the
conscious being knows or experiences the
immediate once it becomes reflected on
shows itself not to be immediate you
know for example you can think about
colors and light
we take colors as being just what they
are we don't realize that they're
actually a product of light until we you
know start monkeying around with the
settings and suddenly we realize that
the settings of the light make a big
difference they mediate the color and
how it appears to us we could go through
a lot of examples of that think it's a
food for example cooking is a form of
mediation Hegel doesn't talk much
okay did much but you could think about
it that way the process of changing
things by applying heat to bring out the
flavors that are in them somebody puts a
plate of food in front of you already
cooked you take that as being something
you mediate it just is what it is now
you bite into it oh that's also
wonderful there was an entire process
and an entire historical process that
culminated in that and the reality of
that is in part the other reality that
you haven't uncovered yet and
reincorporate it into it and when you do
reincorporate that that act of as he
calls it overcoming the other Ness
experience means so much more when we
integrate it with thought with
reflection that's what spirit has been
doing throughout time and that's what
Hegel's trying to chart out
the disparity which exists in
consciousness between the eye and the
substance which is its object is the
distinction between them the negative in
general this can be regarded as the
defect of both though it is their soul
or that which moves them that is why
some of the ancients conceived of the
void is the principle of motion for they
rightly saw the moving principle as the
negative though they did not has yet
grasped that the negative is the self
now although this negative appears that
first is a disparity between the eye and
its object it is just as much the
disparity of the substance with itself
thus what seems to happen outside of it
to be an activity directed against it is
really its own doing and substance shows
itself to be essentially subject when it
has shown this completely spirit has
made its existence identical with its
essence it has itself for its object
just as it is and the abstract element
of immediacy and of the separation of
knowing and truth is overcome being is
then absolutely mediated it is a
substantial content which is just as
immediately the property of the eye it
is self like or the notion with this the
phenomenology of spirit is concluded
what spirit prepares for itself in it is
the element of true knowing in this
element the moments of spirit now spread
themselves out in that form of
simplicity which knows its object as its
own self they no longer fall apart into
the antithesis of being and knowing but
remain in the simple oneness of knowing
they are the true in the form of the
true and their differences only the
difference of content their movement
which organizes itself in this element
into a whole is logic or speculative
philosophy
there are two main movements going on
within section 37 the first one I more
or less charted out here and we'll go
through it in just a moment and the
second one is actually going to lead us
to another work to the configuration of
things that Hagel calls logic and later
on Hagel not much later on Hagel will
write a book called the science of logic
and as a matter of fact there's a little
bit of historical background the the
science of logic and the later
encyclopedia logic that he wrote for a
long time overshadowed the phenomenology
of spirit because the logic presents the
system as completed
whereas the phenomenology of spirit is
us walking through all of the stages and
scrutinizing them and seeing how things
got to to the complex articulated whole
that that they are so we want to keep
that in mind as we're plowing through
this this passage and we'll get to that
that section of that discussion of logic
and in just a moment so he says the
disparity why is he talking about the
disparity well we're gonna see the
importance of the- again what is a
disparity it's when things are not hot
rays when they're not equal they may not
even be comparable at first when we say
apples and oranges you know you're
trying to compare apples and oranges
well you know you can't actually compare
apples and oranges because they are both
round fruit right so they do have a lot
of in common but you know one is a an
apple like fruit you know that includes
pears and quinces and stuff like that
the other one is the citrus fruit pear
or not pairs of oranges are much more
round than apples you know apples tend
to be in a whole variety of colors
oranges
more or less orange you know
but what we're talking about here is not
two things of the same type at least not
at the start turns out that they are
going to be much more similar much more
closely related so Higgins saying look
in consciousness there is a disparity
there is a splitting again there is a
disjunction there is a distinction that
we can make between the eye the
perceiver the act or the one who is
conscious and the object of
consciousness what it is that I am
thinking of what it is that I am aware
of what it is that I am experiencing and
it could be as close you know it doesn't
have to be something way over there it
could be as close as the feeling of the
jacket on my shoulders I am experiencing
that the you know not so tightness but
you know binding this of the tie the
hardness of the collar those are all
things that are to a certain extent
outside of me but in hinging upon me and
I am the one who's aware of them right I
am the subject this is often how we
divide up our experience because our
experience is of things of substances
things that exist things that remain
over time we may not actually be able to
get to the basis of substance a lot of
the time lot could actually be quite
correct about that but we do think that
there's something there that we are
experiencing and we don't think that
that is us we think it's something
different something other something
distinct something not equal to us and
yet it is for us because we are the ones
who are cognizing it if we were acting
about it we are the ones who are not
only acting upon it but intending into
it giving it meaning so
what's really going on there he says
this disparity this distinction between
them is the negative in general remember
we've seen the negative come up before
we're supposed to have patience and
labor with the negative the negative is
this thing that allows us the freedom to
develop the power of the understanding
is is connected with the negative and
here's where he says the negative is
intrinsically connected with movement
that movement in the sense of physical
movement he actually says the ancients
were sort of onto this that's why they
conceived of the void as the principle
of motion so they saw the moving
principle as the negative they didn't
quit grasp the negative as the self as
what it is that we are we are a bunch of
things like I can say I'm on Gregory
Sadler 43 years old you know born in
Wisconsin speaking English
thinking in English occasionally
dreaming in other languages or speaking
other languages but most of the time
English this tall still have 10 fingers
10 toes
no one knows likes to eat this doesn't
like to eat that we can we have all
these sorts of things that we can say
about ourselves I have a number of
memories and probably more than I could
ever count up I'm not gonna do a
pristine task here but we're also
something different from that we're also
the thing that can say I and insofar as
I can say I I distance myself from any
one of those things I am NOT just my
memories I am NOT just my perceptions I
am not just my relations to other things
I am a a free being I am able to act to
intend to choose to move as Hayden was
talking about it so he says although the
negative appears at first as the
disparity between the eye and its object
it's just as much the disparity within
the sub
or the object with itself where is that
going to get revealed later on we're
gonna see that get revealed in the
process of charting out what
consciousness reveals to us these things
that we take to be immediate don't turn
out to be immediate they turn out to
have these bifurcations and splittings
within themselves when we look at them
also within the subject there's going to
be a splitting taking place within there
here is where the secret comes in this
over here we take as being something
independent of us something standing
against us that impinges upon us that's
why we perceive it that's why we suffer
it in in some cases but Hegel says if we
look at it in the right perspective we
realize that in a certain way it's
actually us this is what we call
idealism reality is fundamentally not
things that are totally independent of
mind consciousness what it is that we
are but actually extensions or
projections of it that take on a certain
sort of independence a certain sort of
agency just as we are not exactly what
we are
there's the objects within ourselves as
well and we're all within for Hegel
spirit so he says what seems to happen
outside of it to be an activity directed
against it is really its own doing
substance shows itself to be and it's
truth
it's subject where do we have subject
over here so these are actually both
subject what that means is that not only
am i sort of tied up with all the things
that I'm perceiving knowing acting upon
wishing for intending desiring those
things are also rooted in me at the same
time there's a back and forth here
neither one of them is independent of
the other so he says when it is shown
this completely spirit has made its
essence identical with existence now
that's a very important phrase because
what being has its essence identical
with its existence in traditional
philosophy and traditional theology god
no does that mean that I'm God because
I'm the subject I'm the the
phenomenologist charting out all this
stuff no that doesn't mean that I'm God
or Hegel is God but it means that for
Hegel what's going on with this march of
spirit through time getting to know
itself better and better is God
developing God's self through human
agency through human beings through
human consciousness in time that's going
to make him pretty heterodox to most
Christian thinkers it's interesting just
to see how many generations a lot of
Orthodox Christian thinkers had to go
through to embrace Hegel be in the 19th
century but there is also a strong
reaction against him for that same
reason so he says when it show this
completely spirit is made its essence
its existence identical with its essence
that's a big achievement it is it has
itself for its object just as it is the
abstract element of immediacy the
separation of knowing which is something
on the part of the subject and truth on
the part of the object the separation
between them just as much as the
separation between
subject an object has been overcome how
has it been overcome by just fusing them
together
no by showing the interconnections
between all of these things by plotting
it out by laying it into this this vast
conceptual map that you can kind of
picture in your head but it takes a lot
of work to do the more that you work on
it the better you get at it so he says
being is then absolutely mediated being
is mediated which means that it was
always mediated from the beginning we
just were mixed up about it and now we
come to really understand the way things
are I come to understand that I am NOT
what I assumed that I was a totally
independent being that just perceives
things that don't impinge upon me aren't
part of my consciousness and that those
things aren't what they appeared to be
at first either so he says with this the
phenomenology of spirit is concluded
kind of a weird thing to say in the
preface isn't it especially when he is
at the halfway point of the preface he's
in haven't done a bit the preface but
the phenomenology of spirit is concluded
what spirit prepares for itself in it is
the element of true knowing it brings
together truth and and knowledge and it
makes knowledge not just knowledge of
truth but knowledge that is itself truth
so he says in this element the moments
of spirit now spread themselves out in
the form of simplicity which knows its
object as its own self they no longer
fall apart into the antithesis of being
and knowing but remain in the simple
oneness of knowing they're the true in
the form of the true and their
difference is only there's still
difference there difference of content
everything has been thought out
everything has been made sense up
everything has been understood and now
it's just a matter of sort of like
laying the whole thing out this is he
says
their movement which organizes itself
into a whole is logic or speculative
philosophy so the phenomenology will
eventually lead us to a culmination
point ah logic where now we actually
understand the totality and we don't
understand it by facing everything or
fusing everything into one single primal
experience the way some mystics want to
do rather it's by grasping the totality
in all of its articulate nests all of
its connections all of its mediations
and seeing how they actually connect up
with each other kind of tough to do that
means that if we want to have this
viewpoint of the whole we ourselves have
to develop on the way to become adequate
to what it is that Hegel is able to show
us like most important books this is
probably a great way to close this this
particular discussion like most great
books we don't just read the book the
book reads us the book should change us
the book should be an obstacle course
that requires us to get strong or smart
or tougher more more resourceful to make
sense out of what is in the book and
this is going to be a back and forth
kind of process so you know what that
really means is if you're struggling
with Hegel first off you're not alone I
still struggle with a clone I've been
reading the guy now for close to 20
years but if you're struggling with
Hegel that could be in part because of
the difficulty of what it is that he's
trying to set out for you and you're
going through the birth pangs the
growing pains that are required in order
for you to develop what it is that you
need in order to be able to grasp more
and more fully what he's talking about